negotiations between ukraine and russia
have failed to deliver any significant
progress toward ending moscow's 12-day
war even before the talks began ukraine
had rejected a russian proposal to
create humanitarian corridors for
civilians to escape now most of the
corridors would have led to russia or to
its ally belarus a plan ukraine had
called immoral a ukrainian delegation
today flew to belarus for that third
round of negotiations with russia which
have now concluded ukraine said there
have been small positive steps but no
significant improvements
russia also cautioned against hope for a
major outcome
and meanwhile russian forces are
continuing to attack cities across
ukraine south and east and a ukraine
army chief has warned that russian
troops are preparing to storm the
capital
[Music]
the ukrainian national anthem echoes
across kiev
[Music]
but just a few miles from the capital
people continue to seek safety from the
ongoing russian assault
meanwhile the mayor of kramatorsk said
two people were killed
and six wounded in missile strikes in
the eastern ukrainian city
on monday russia's defense ministry
released this footage
purporting to show tanks advancing
towards kiev
but ukrainians are determined it won't
be taken
without a fight
volunteers are helping protect their
capital
but there are no guarantees it will be
enough
as diplomatic efforts continue ukrainian
president vladimir zelensky remained
defiant in his message
we will not forgive the shooting of
unarmed people the destruction of our
infrastructure
we won't forgive the creation of
hundreds and hundreds of victims the
suffering of thousands and thousands of
people and god won't forgive not today
not tomorrow
a spokesperson for russia's defense
ministry has announced a number of
humanitarian corridors
those fleeing kiev have been offered
passage to neighboring belarus
while those in kharkiv an escape to
russia itself
this is an unacceptable option for
opening humanitarian corridors
our people will not go from ivankov from
deemer from vishkarad from near kiev to
belarus in order to then fly to russia
the only major city captured by the
russians people have displayed their
defiant objection
standing their ground even as the
occupiers fire guns above their heads
[Music]
joining me now is maria sirichenko from
mario paul that's one of the cities
that's been under siege for more than a
week now and she's left her home to
escape to the western city of the vive
and she joins me from there a very warm
welcome maria thank you so much for
taking the time under these terrible
circumstances
over the past few days you've been
speaking to my colleagues and you've
told us that your grandmother is still
in mario paul have you had a chance to
hear from her and find out how she's
doing
thanks for having me unfortunately i
haven't heard from my grandmother for a
week already and today is still nothing
so
yeah
what i left is hope and pray
that she's
alive and she's healthy
and have you been able to hear from
anyone else who is still in the city
not much really because
today i think in the morning the last uh
cell uh tower was destroyed but
yesterday morning we were able to hear
some you know sms from from a few of
people and
they shared that the situation is still
really terrible they still have nothing
in terms of food
they don't have any heat they don't have
any connection and what is the most the
scariest thing for me is that the city
is out of water
so people tried to drink rain water or
even some of
my clothes people they tried to
go to sea to gather some sea water but
it's salty obviously so no water no food
no heat
in this cold denied of these basic
services in addition to what you've
described trying to find water how are
people there uh trying to survive
well i think what uh
what helps them is the sense of unity
and sense of determination because
people believe that it will end soon
and uh they try to help each other as
they can but
they have fear just to go out of their
homes because
the city has been constantly bombed by
russians
that's why there is no chance for them
to escape
and so-called humanitarian corridor
attempts they failed both times
i do want to ask you about those
humanitarian corridors especially from
mario paul were they at any point seeing
what was russia's offer at any point
seen as a realistic option for people to
escape
um
today's uh
not today really but yesterday and a few
days ago there were a few attempts like
official attempts to organize those
corridors and even some people who had
at least some connection they tried to
organize in the center of the city to
get on bus and escape from the city of
mariota but once they tried to
actually go out of the city russians
continued shooting and shelling and
nothing um nothing happened in terms of
success
and today um russians offered these
corridors but to the occupied
territories which is absolutely
unacceptable and people just don't have
any um
that russians will really help them so
they
choose to stay and
just hope that ukrainian people will
help them go out of the city if the
ukrainian government is able to find an
agreement that is able to create a
humanitarian corridor i mean will people
trust themselves to leave their homes
and wherever they may be taking shelter
to try and actually leave ukraine given
the russian shelling that happened um
the last time they made the attempt
absolutely um because people want to
save their life and of course half of
the state of marupo is right now
almost destroyed because every minute
they hear bombs and attacks but if they
have a chance from ukrainian government
to save their life and leave the city
and escape this war zone
i'm sure that many of them will be able
to do that i'm not sure about my grandma
because she is 80 years old and
i'm not sure she will really
be able to survive during this whole
trip you know out of ukraine because she
needs to take medicines she needs to
take some
uh
food and drink and water every day and
i just wanted to have some connection
with her
i'm so sorry to hear about your grandma
um we are happy that you've managed to
make it to levive because western
ukraine appears to be uh safer compared
to the rest of the country can you tell
us a little bit about what the situation
is like there
well in leaf there are a lot of people
coming from uh eastern parts of ukraine
like kiev or harkev and
people are volunteering everywhere here
we have maybe thousands of volunteers
who want to help the army who try to buy
medicines who try to organize some
shelters because a lot of people need
some shelter because of
the huge traffic coming from the capital
of ukraine
and people really believe that we will
win and i'm 100 sure that it will happen
soon so
i think this uh sense of unity helps
people to uh stay strong even in such a
horrible situation all right maria we're
going to leave it there thank you again
for joining us and giving us a glimpse
of this terrible situation please take
care
thank you
so for more let's bring in dw
correspondent nick connolly who is
reporting for us from ukraine's capital
kiev nick good to see you there um these
previous two rounds of talks have
clearly failed to end the bloodshed what
are we hearing has come out of round
three
well all that we've been hearing from
the negotiating team the ukrainian
negotiation team
is pretty modest stuff it's about
technicalities about making a
humanitarian corridor work but we've
seen those fail in the last few days i
think it's basically about the optics
right now neither side can afford to not
be at those talks to stand accused of
not being interested in peace but
actually if you look at their
negotiating positions the russians
they've slightly turned down their
rhetoric they went into this war with
very bombastic rhetoric about demanding
denarification of ukraine whatever that
means and basically ukraine to kind of
fully capitulate now they just want
ukraine to recognize russian ownership
of crimea they want kiev to recognize
those self-proclaimed republics in the
east and they want
kiev to also
basically put in its constitution that
it will stay neutral um those are
basically the the full maximalistic
demands they started off with the
ukrainians obviously
cheered and buoyed by pretty extensive
successes on the battlefield so this is
different situation in the air where
russia still has that superiority but on
the battlefield ukraine is doing uh an
extraordinary amount of damage to those
russian troops lots of prisons of wars
being taken so there isn't a sense on
either side that it is time to cut
losses for now both sides still sticking
to their maximum demands ukraine wanting
those russian troops out without any
kind of uh
you know concession in return so i think
for now it's about the optics about
keeping talking but i don't think anyone
has any real expectations that
something's gonna come out of these
talks so tell me more about those
humanitarian corridors that you
mentioned the people are desperate to
get out but previous efforts have failed
is there any hope that that might change
now
again i hate to be the bringer of bad
news but i think there's very little
chance especially you have to think now
this is a time where hundreds of
soldiers are being killed every day on
both sides and you know the idea that
these two sides are going to bilaterally
just the two of them without outside
mediation
have even the basic trust to make this
kind of thing work i think is
unfortunately a little optimistic we've
seen even this more modest attempts to
organize humanitarian corridors for
mario paul city of several hundred
thousand people that are now trapped in
eastern ukraine with russian troops all
around the sea on the other side that
has twice failed so the idea that some
more ambitious scheme for a wider
humanitarian corridor across ukraine
could work i think for now is a little
early um this is a situation that is
getting worse people in some cities now
have been without power without water
without mobile phone coverage for days
people having to start eating the their
supplies their tins their kind of
emergency supplies that they put down
going into this crisis so there is
definitely a situation that's getting
worse by the day and the impact on
ordinary civilians is going to get worse
as this drags on
now in cube where you are there is has
of course also been an immense russian
military convoy building up outside of
at the capitol what is the sense in kiev
of what's to come
i think in the early days of this war
there was a hope that somehow ukraine
could reach ordinary russians we saw
lots of ukrainian pop stars youtubers
people have a following in russia trying
to
directly address people in russia get
those people out on the streets of
moscow petersburg other cities to
protest to try and put pressure on the
russian government to draw back to end
this war i think lots of ukrainians now
are increasingly disillusioned and less
willing to believe that the russian
broader population even if they're
against this war are willing to risk
anything and actually come out against
this i think in ukraine now also there's
increasing disillusionment with the west
yes the west is giving weapons but not
as many another kind that ukraine wants
nato has refused to close the skies to
create a no-fly zone over the country
which would allow ukraine to push you
know its uh advantage on the ground
through and to really make inroads into
that russian advance so i think there is
an increasing kind of understanding here
in ukraine that basically ukraine can
only rely on itself its own army and
people are increasingly believing that
they might even have a chance against
russia given how many difficulties the
russians are having with logistics how
many problems they're having with their
own hardware lots of which is in a lot
worse condition than was expected so
it's basically a question of sitting
this out and trying to
keep on going until somehow miraculously
maybe ukraine is able to push these
russian troops out or the russians
decide to call it quits but i think the
hope that somehow russian civil society
would
weigh in and prevent the kremlin from
doing this i think that is unfortunately
a hope that is uh growing increasingly
um
scarce among ordinary ukrainians
dw's nick connolly reporting for us from
keefe thank you so much as always
so how are russians viewing this
invasion let's find out from dw russian
affairs analyst constantine egard
constantine thousands of people have
been arrested at protests across russia
is there a possibility that russians
could stop vladimir putin's invasion
oh frankly i agree with nick
i think there is very little possibility
of it now at least now i would say
although the number of arrests was huge
uh even compared to the
arrest during the protests called for by
the opposition leader alexey navalny
who's now in jail
about a year ago or something um it's
comparable but it's still not a lot for
a country of 140 million plus people
uh i think that uh also the repression
is tightening today there was a
partially confirmed footage of people
being checked randomly by police on the
streets of at least big cities like
moscow they were asked to produce their
mobile phones and the police scrolled
the phones looking for probably uh
messages against the war or what kind of
telegram channels people are eating
those who refused were reportedly taken
to the police precincts again that has
to be verified but frankly i wouldn't be
surprised because i think the government
wants to really nip it in the butt also
i suppose the kremlin is probably
concerned about the geography of these
protests uh 18 or 19 cities in russia
count population of uh one million or
more but the geography is much wider
it's i think about 50 cities where the
arrests were made that means that there
are
russian-style fairly small places like
places with
300 400 000 population
in such places people who protest are
much better now
and the protest spreads much quicker
protests or at least news of protests
spread much quicker if you combine it
with the
impending i think redundancies huge
redundancies at uh
factories that close at businesses that
close
eventually what may shake the foundation
it's not the peace movement as such
but the peace movement combined with
workers that are discontent that may be
a much bigger problem for putin than the
big city intelligence students that are
mostly those who rally against the war
now okay so it's a dangerous situation
for citizens who might be against the
war i also want to ask you about those
small places you mentioned in russia i
mean are they feeling the effects of
russia's invasion of ukraine
not yet but
the speed with which
basically western business withdraws
from russia
uh will also mean that a lot of russian
companies will collapse that is
inevitable
just to give you an example and it's
something that i've only seen probably
once in my lifetime in 1998 when russia
defaulted on its debt international debt
uh the uh uh the currency uh currency
rates today are actually well the dollar
and the ruble gained a hundred percent
over what they used to be let's say 10
days ago
so it's
really something that is going to impact
russia which was built into the global
economy very much so okay you have the
adidas or
let us say what uh major car makers
withdrawing but they were served by a
lot of other companies which are russian
companies so
these companies are inevitably going to
go out of business or slash style that
means that lots of people will feel
what's happening quite soon but probably
not really tomorrow and the state the
russian state will have a big problem
dealing with that too because there's a
lot of people discontent momentarily
okay they will be feeling the pinch then
dw's russian affairs analyst constantine
edgar thanks so much for joining us on
the show
how are russians viewing this invasion
let's put that to our russia analyst
roman gonzalenko he joins me now uh is
there a possibility that russians could
stop vladimir putin's war in ukraine
well a lot of ukrainians hoped for that
but i would be very very careful
well we've seen that uh russian
propaganda is very effective it is
working and it has been working for
years so um when we look at the state
polls in russia they show that up to
three-fourths of the russian population
actually support vladimir's putin
actions in ukraine
some
independent polls
make a different picture but not very
much so we've seen for example um
estimates of the
uh levada center in moscow um they say
um up to two-thirds of russian so 60
plus
support the current uh russian actions
in ukraine support this war so i would
say um it is possible that russians
could stop vladimir putin but but there
are a few russians who can do that it's
a minority
and domestically what effect has this
invasion had on russian
society well this effect is very much um
underestimated i would say especially in
um certain areas like for example spare
parts for cars or western car
manufacturers or in general i would say
this this tendency when western
companies are leaving russia i think
this is something that no one really
expected when they planned this
operation i think this is something that
is hitting russians very much and um
also that the west is
excluding russian from from air travel
blocking russian ships um worldwide
sending russian
athletes home not allowing them to
participate in in in competitions this
is something i think that is that the
russia underestimated and this influence
will grow it will it will grow and the
frustration within the russian society
will also grow
i want to ask you more about the west
response response because the u.s and
poland they've been discussing the
delivery of fighter jets to ukraine does
that signal nato's direct involvement in
this conflict
well it's disputable russia has been
warning nato not to do such things and
we've seen today
new warnings from the russian foreign
minister the spokeswoman said that
sending troops to ukraine western
western fighters who would fight on the
ukrainian side or
bringing um fighter jets to ukraine
sending this this kind of weapons to
ukraine would lead to a catastrophe she
said so there is a clear warning on the
russian side from president putin and
from the foreign minister not to do that
but on the other hand i've spoken to a
an expert today a british expert and he
said we have to try this we have to try
this and see what russian reaction would
be because we've seen a deliveries to
ukraine of western weapons and um it it
hasn't been um
there was no no strong reaction from
from russia i would say so russia
expected possibly things like that but
the reaction has been relatively
moderate
dw's russia analyst roman goncharenko
thank you so much for joining us with
that update
you